اخيرا كتاب سيره الامير هاري على رفوف
المكتبات والمتاجر صار في متناول محبي
الامير وكاريه على السواق لتصفح الصفحات
ال 416 وما تحتويه من فيض من التفاصيل
المثيره عن حياته وعن الخلافه داخل عائلته
من كشفه عن مشاجره مع اخيه وصولا الى
اعترافه بقتل 25 مقاتلا في طالبان وكلامه
عن طاعه المخدرات كلها امور اثارت ردود
فعل عديده وستترك بلا شك اثرا على مبيعات
الكتاب وشعبيه الامير
اشتريت الكتاب لانني اريد ان اكون جزءا من
التاريخ ولمعرفتي ما جرى في القصر خصوصا
الامور التي لم نسمع عنها من قبل وكيف
تصرفت الصحافه مع
هاريونيه للامير هاري لترويج كتابه ومزعم
مثيره طالت افراد العائله الملكيه صدمت
متابع الامير وعائلته من جهه ومؤيد
العائله المالكه من جهه اخرى وان كانت
الغالبيه ترى ضروره ابقاء اسرار العائله
الملكيه ومشاكل اعضائها حديثه القصر لن
اقتني الكتاب لاننا قضينا وقتا كافيا
للحديث عن هذا الموضوع وحصل على ما يكفي
من الدعايه ولا اظن ان من المنطقي شراء
الكتاب
قد لا اشتري الكتاب وليس لدي شيء ضد
الكتاب اتعاطف مع الامير لكن لا اظن انه
يستحق اضاعه وقتي لقراءته
سيجني الامير هاري الملايين من الجنيهات
من مبيعات الكتاب وسيخص جزء منها لمنظمه
خيريه اسسها لمساعده الاطفال المصابين
بفيروس نقص المناعه في افريقيا
يحتلوا كتابه مذكرات الامير هاري المرتبه
الاولى في قوائم مبيعات الكتب على موقع
امازون ويتوقعوا ان يحضر كتابه باقبال
كبير في المكتبات بعد حمله التسويقيه منذ
الاعلامي عن نشر سيرته الذاتيه
كعادتها التزمت العائله الملكيه السمطه
ولم تعلق على مزاعم الكتاب تركه الكلام
لهاري ولقراء ليحكموا على تداعيات اصداره
على المدى الطويل مصطفى زارو العربيه لندن